so this is beyond the wild and before
that remember remembrances let's just
wait it wet I'm sure you're wondering
why didn't you do a talk about
remembrances it's frail and doesn't know
it in here it's a fucking clip shots a
fucking clip show but to their credit
the creators released this statement
that sounded pretty bitter and angry
yeah in the most diplomatic way possible
they were just like Nickelodeon fucked
us and so now unfortunately we have to
fuck you and not in the good way
but more like the bend over and just
take but honestly with them just coming
out and admitting that I'm Carrick okay
oh that was the best move they could
have made yeah I like honestly the end
result of this is everybody feels bad
for the creators and is like what the
fuck Nickelodeon are you guys just run
by rhesus monkeys I the hell I at this
point I mean my guess is they're because
so much drama has been caused over all
this and so I'm sure they're just like
you know what I don't think we're gonna
work here again let's just I mean they
should not like burning the originals
nobody in the right mind should be
working for Nickelodeon right now period
I mean obviously the inmates are running
the asylum well they've been talking
what would you say like there's even
talk about like cuz now it's kind of
back on TV rats on news site or some
like tonight new no traffic like after
all of this after all of this horse shit
after all of this nick says a couple
days after this release c'mon oh well
you know what we're gonna run it on TV
on one of our like other affiliate
networks Nick not Sponge Bob for 24/7
Network or whatever they've got running
so I'm sitting here and I'm like so wait
a second you mean I've been watching
this online for the past like what six
seven weeks now and you were gonna
release it anyway on TV what the fuck
so come on there's talk about whether or
not this was like a big conspiracy don't
like drive traffic to other places I
mean it could be in number things one
they could have just wanted to drive
people to the website to begin with even
though they knew they were going to
release this on some of his station
- they could be trying to drum up you
know people to go watch their other
bullshit station now or whatever three
they could have seen the backlash that's
sprung from when the creators came out
and said yeah this is how Nick screwed
us if we're just like oh well maybe we
should give them a token gift to pretend
make we care but it's not working all of
the critics basically came out and were
just like are you kidding us Nickelodeon
like who do you think is buying this
shit well I do it there is I will admit
there is something funny to just like
you know fuck you Nickelodeon we're
getting so angry like a kids now but
it's like it's the one show that's
really it's all zone it's the one show
that's really adult on there and you
don't treat your people like that like
that's really what it comes down to it's
like oh yeah we want and here's your
budget now oops
no we're taking your budget away so the
creators and that's the thing had this
just happened out of nowhere like
without the history that the show yeah I
probably I don't anybody yeah nobody
would have cared we were like oh some
people are complain but it's like when
we be complaining we're like Oh clip
show this sucks but to have the creators
come out and have to explain this
because yeah after getting dicked around
this much for four seasons of this show
and just getting burned again and again
and again this is like the final insult
like and to have the creator's have to
come out and explain hey we didn't want
it this way we decided to do it this way
so that our people could get paid just
there it is Nickelodeon well and things
been and enjoy whenever we see a clip
show it's like cuz we forgot Ares and
people talking so we kind of know it's
like clip shows are a way to save money
to focus on other episodes oh God you
know MSR Korra has never done that and
in the case of ember island players that
wasn't even a clip show that was a
really it was a recap that they
reanimated the entire thing from scratch
they were clever about it and it came
right before the giant finale this just
seems randomly placed to me like the
funny thing about because there's not
much to say it is mostly clip show the
only thing that I was like the last
third is serve told through mayor
Rick's a very uh in that part of you
illegal area yeah and it's one of those
things where it's like why wasn't the
whole thing like this it's like I'm sure
like they just had to rush and think of
something really fast and they have I'm
sure looking back they're like crap we
should have made all of this Varrick
telling the story it would have made it
better I mean I can't I can't fault the
craters we look you shocked at your clip
show that you had to do like I see for
what it was it was the best that could
have happened I a lot of people thinking
that I was ripping on the creators for
it being um no I they get off scot-free
as far as I'm concerned this is more
people are like for clip show wasn't
have been I agree it could have been a
lot worse and that that's not the best
recommendation why didn't wanna could
have been worse instead of first third
the first third or two-thirds of it
could have been a lot worse it did what
it needed to do it's okay and the third
part was legitimately hilarious yeah you
know that's what I'm saying like it for
a clip show like this came out pretty
good that's not the issue the issue is
not the quality of clip show it's the
fact that Nickelodeon forced them
basically to either not do a show at all
you know you no doubt a full basic cut
out X out a full episode or make it a
clip show cuz it sounds like this was
not done in the song yet this wasn't
done at the big game cuz I'm looking at
this like way did you wouldn't do a clip
show and have all these shots of just
the camera like panning to the left or
something and have it all CG descends
like no they would know the budget
better this was something they said the
budget out of nowhere was slashed to the
point that amounted to about an episode
so they said okay so let's you know save
an episode you know it employment for
these animators and stuff and have one
that's just a real fast easy clip show
yeah oh I don't know they're not they're
not fooling me so oh we care about core
and we're gonna give it a run on TV you
don't give a flying fuck don't even try
Nickelodeon don't even try your time and
wonder what you're talking about you're
talking like it's the bully of like your
kid or something like that a listen here
you little punk
you leave my tour alone okay I don't
like it I don't like it when art gets
dicked around by people who don't know
jack shit about art and the end product
suffers for it like we're not talking
about
business that has saved kora its
Nickelodeon that is wrecked kora almost
from the beginning like that bothers me
and then to come out and try to pretend
at the last when we're giving it a run
on TV I'm like bullshit you didn't care
about this show to begin with so that it
just really bothers me and yes I'm angry
and bitter about that because this has
been going on since season one and then
right before the end we could even go
out on a strong point we had to have the
final insult with them forcing a clip
show in an otherwise pretty perfect
season so fast so is this making of ways
we should probably get to this angle
enough about that this is an episode um
it puts short nobody really kind of
wants Korra again like in real life
um but nobody kind of wants her because
they feel like she can't handle Shari
lost this one major fight and she's
feeling kind of useless and stuff so she
tries to go in the spirit world and
finds the bag from the last season's out
here as I hear it is there it's not even
the spirit world it's like this memory
and he's like blocking her somehow so
she feels if she goes and sees him all
locked up in prison and stuff that's
somehow confronting him will help uh
goes there talks to him he kind of
sporadically wants to help that's like
my one problem is there's just like you
know yes I heard she's crazy
we must stop her it's like where'd this
come from I'm all about chaos but you
know maybe we didn't lose an episode to
a clip show it could have been drawn out
more it made more sense but um so but I
know I don't disagree with you there but
it does his motivation does make sense
kind of like the the fight we had in
that other episode between Asami and
Cory it's just rushed too much yeah
motivation right makes total sense
because he just has found out everything
he wanted to do in season three is not
only been undone but what he didn't want
to have happen was a giant dictator
running everything is now so he's like
you know what alliance of convenience
that's what I didn't want to have happen
but it's a yes yeah yeah I'm not
faulting the logic and faulting the how
quickly came to it and kind of the same
thing with her coming to her realization
that she has to really give herself into
happened and not run away from it it's
we kind of were doing before but this is
a little different this was as much
getting the poison out as much as like
kind of really going back to that moment
and like kind of like a better term kind
of dying in that moment if that makes
sense I don't I don't disagree so if I
would have liked maybe half an episode
at least going into that wherever this
year's like only we had an extra 24
minutes oh no no you needed them ever be
anything I needed a pillow to scream
into oh he'll never be the same
um but and then on top of that we have
the the vines in in Republic City the
spirit vines are trying to attack people
and stuff and that's one of the reasons
quartz trying to help cuz she's trying
to help these people out and she finds
out that general Zelda's going and she's
taking these branches and she's going to
create this babbit are literally when
avatar yes it's like this is literally
something out of the pot a avatar we
chop down a big tree why that no it's
not the tree that's why I thought oh it
is it reminds it's which I'm not
admittedly all with the giant with the
mech robots they're like you're all
thinking like it's okay I know that no I
it's okay I think it's it's not a bad
plop no say about somebody can see your
world involved no the branches makes
more sense yeah I really felt it's just
gonna cut down the whole tree it may
because we have seen like Fern Gully an
avatar and stuff like that but I like
that more we just need these elements we
don't want it's been a it's been pretty
underplayed like I I honestly I think
it's cool so I don't mind that but it
did make me think of effet are the movie
uh so she confronts as she feels better
um it's a lobby episode and Korra feels
better um and yeah she goes off and now
there go and uh Bolin and uh other
flying chick without you man forget it
Oh
caught me on the yeah see it's gonna say
Jinora
it's that Jinora uh his babble ins
girlfriend um yeah I'm forgetting our
name but they're gonna go on the beef oh
yes
they're gonna go and save the family
because in this very honored a phone
like you know granddaughter beifong I
guess cuz if Linda let's go to the chart
you want to charge uh oh it's gonna piss
me off all day I'm gonna be trying to
remember that name I'm sure nobody in
the comments will tell us at all that
I've been correcting you too and now
they're gonna get me on one it's been a
while it's been a while uh so kuvira by
the way not zone
I like generals I actually like generals
Elvis yeah so uh we all Isis if so yeah
so they're now they're going to go off
and go try and save the family because
they had this long conversation about
why they won't get involved with a
preemptive strike uh which again is a
lot talking a lot of strategy you know a
lot of it I liked it I liked the fire
nations very post-world War two Japanese
obnoxious you know we've kind of been
doing this for a while now and we're
kind of out so if you want any help to
help a defense we're the guys to call
but we don't think we should go marching
into other nations we got kind of a
history there you know there I like how
this seems like that it seems to be
alive this season especially have a lot
of sitting down and talking with usually
like through something but everything
they're talking about has such weight to
it and I think even for a kid I remember
watching the x-men cartoon growing up
and I remember I didn't follow
everything about like the mutant
Registration step but I I felt adult
watching it and I kind of wanted to know
more and I wanted to try and understand
it and we feel like having which is why
honestly being on something like
Nickelodeon is not bad cuz it's like
well okay this is a kid show is for me
but I'm not getting I kind of want to
get it I want to understand it so I like
no no need to watch more Sponge Bob um
so yeah and the one thing I like the
most out of this uh I don't know why
this episode particularly but something
about the interactions off of everybody
even though it eventually turns into a
chorus entered episode well everybody
got back together for one thing yeah I
love bolin and varrick marching in like
now we have top secret information well
we really should have led with that one
yeah you know i I something about just
the whole episode seen a lot of like
just people interacting off of other
people it's been not for comedy but just
legit
working off each other well did you
guess the theme of this episode is
alliance of convenience
yeah you've got like we've got Varrick
and Asami shaking hands with her nearly
breaking it off which was really cool I
love that scene um we've got Bolin going
off with goddammit her hers this is
we're gonna get such shit for that um
yeah and those two don't like each other
in the moment like this they're bonding
over this you know going to war on
mother and then we got and then we got
Korra and Zaheer with the hannibal
lecter moment yeah I love that image of
him floating in the chains I think
that's great yeah
so it you know and even amongst the
council it seems like there was some
disagree when they're coming together
just to agree on defense so it's like
yeah everybody's making all of these
connections I feel like we're getting
into like the the final sort of fight
like is coming up now within the next
three or four episodes and how many are
left but but yeah I really enjoyed it
yeah you see what I mean though there's
something about like it's not that
wasn't in the other dubs usually like
we're gonna focus on this group and then
just this group it may be this person
this person they say about this one
where everyone like a lot of the main
characters all seem to kind of be in it
and they all sort of talked and worked
off each other in a way that just seemed
like you know you could almost get like
some of these lines to like a a guard or
something like that or in general
whatever but it's the fact that it's
these characters you seem working off
each or you just feel to come robbery a
lot more in this one I don't know why
something about this one in particular I
really felt that and it's not like they
put a ton of focus on or anything it
just felt very natural and I really like
that about this one um great Varrick
line two and you blew up the southern
cultural say hey that was my building
should I have the right to blow up my
own building yeah very still it's that
guy could do no wrong he wasn't this
part even in the clip show um so no he
was he just that quadruple phone call
between unalaq and Amman yes I hear and
just play the keys off the line I'm
still here
oh crap um so yeah I mean I think it's a
strong episode again kind of it's nice
to sort of see even though it feel kind
of rushed it's nice to see coarser over
this thing and I
I like that angle a novel legasus are
really getting yourself into like the
fear to a point where it's like you
almost died in that fear but like after
you go through that like all the way you
out about letting go yeah which I like I
mean it's even though we kind of did
that before it's yeah it felt a little
different than saying it felt different
enough I should say um so so yeah I like
it was just brush but I I think letting
go is a good moral which is why I may
forgive Nick in time it's 2025 years
maybe even the letting go it seems like
there's a sense it's like she was ready
to move on she was ready to move on but
it was still like there and I like the
idea of like oh she didn't say I'll
never really get over it yeah but I've
learned to deal with it that's that will
be my approach to Nick yeah I sort of
like going you with eyes are like the
aspect of just like you know no don't
resist it like throw yourself into that
pan yourself into the fear like you know
like I said almost like just sorta yeah
it's the fight club scene it's when he's
pouring the wire was the other said it's
like come on don't pretend to go away
like all those dying people do you know
feel it yeah I like really embrace in
which there's a lot of planning to do I
learn from that ah now don't stay there
twice and myself every day yeah I'm
gonna get my somebody eye with a fork
every after this uh can I help
I'm good enough on my own thank you
maybe you can hold the camera sweet Evan
I dyed it everyone's like staring over
the fork I'm like that on camera at best
for my own pleasure uh so yeah so it I
like that that was a good episode and
don't know how many are left but um yeah
looking for excited to watch out the
final episode will be a big show general
Zelda there is Jessica she's gone let's
remember all the fun times we had and
budget cats
so there it is I'm going to let you grow
yourself to peace a place of accepting
until you can forgive Nick for what has
happened
fuck acceptance I need a scotch
okay Lefroy